su cirujano realizará un reemplazo de
válvula aórtica en caso de que su
válvula aórtica no esté funcionando de
forma adecuada el corazón es un órgano
muscular que bombea sangre a todo el
cuerpo está conformado por cuatro
cámaras las cámaras superiores son los
atrios izquierdo y derecho
las cámaras inferiores son los
ventrículos izquierdo y derecho los
atrios izquierdo y derecho se conectan
con sus respectivos ventrículos el
ventrículo derecho se conecta con la
arteria pulmonar y el ventrículo
izquierdo con la aorta las válvulas se
ubican en estas conexiones para asegurar
que la sangre se mueva en una sola
dirección las partes de una válvula que
se abren y cierran son colgajos de
tejido llamados balbás la válvula
aórtica se ubica entre el ventrículo
izquierdo y la aorta cuando el corazón
se contrae la válvula aórtica se abre y
la sangre se bombea hacia la aorta
cuando el corazón se relaja se cierra
para evitar que la sangre regrese al
ventrículo izquierdo
una válvula aórtica normal tiene 3
balbás lisas que se abren ampliamente y
se cierra bien su válvula aórtica puede
tener fugas o ser muy estrecha lo que
ocasiona que su corazón trabaje más e
interrumpa su flujo sanguíneo una
válvula con fugas no cierra por completo
lo que ocasiona que la sangre regrese al
ventrículo entre cada latido esta
condición se llama insuficiencia aórtica
una válvula aórtica estrecha no se abre
por completo lo que restringe la
cantidad de sangre que sale desde el
ventrículo hacia la aorta esta condición
se llama estenosis aórtica es posible
que haya nacido con una válvula aórtica
anormal por ejemplo es posible que su
válvula aórtica sólo tenga dos balbás en
lugar de tres de tal modo que no se
abren y cierran adecuadamente es posible
que su válvula aórtica se haya dañado
durante su vida una condición llamada
valvulopatía aórtica adquirida las
causas incluyen fiebre reumática la cual
puede ser una complicación de una
de garganta por estreptococos no tratada
endocarditis que es una infección
bacteriana de la válvula y esclerosis o
endurecimiento de las valvas aórticas
después de cierto tiempo una válvula
aórtica defectuosa puede ocasionar que
los músculos del corazón se agranden y
debiliten dependiendo de la naturaleza
del defecto de la válvula las paredes
del ventrículo izquierdo pueden volverse
más gruesas o delgadas de forma anormal
y a la larga el problema también puede
afectar el lado derecho del corazón los
pacientes con esta condición conocida
como insuficiencia cardíaca pueden
experimentar falta de aliento dolor en
el pecho o angina de pecho mareos
aturdimiento y o desmayos hinchazón en
los tobillos pies y piernas y fatiga
el reemplazo de válvula aórtica se
realiza para devolver a la válvula su
funcionamiento normal
antes del procedimiento se le colocará
una vía intravenosa en el brazo para
proporcionarle líquidos y medicamentos
se le insertará un catéter en la vejiga
para drenar la orina los reemplazos de
válvula aórtica se llevan a cabo bajo
anestesia general esto significa que
usted estará dormido durante toda la
operación y que se colocará un tubo por
su boca hasta su tráquea para ayudarlo a
respirar durante la cirugía
una vez que la anestesia haga efecto el
cirujano comenzará haciendo una incisión
en el pecho la incisión tradicional se
hace en el medio del pecho por encima
del esternón
luego el cirujano separa el esternón
para exponer el pericardio que es una
membrana protectora que recubre el
corazón a continuación el cirujano
abrirá el pericardio para exponer el
corazón en este momento su corazón será
conectado a una máquina de circulación
extracorpórea se utilizan tubos para
redirigir su sangre a esta máquina la
cual se encarga de las funciones del
corazón y los pulmones durante la
operación una vez que la máquina de
circulación extracorpórea se hace cargo
de dichas funciones su corazón se
detendrá temporalmente y extraerá la
sangre en su interior esto mantiene
quieta la válvula aórtica y le permite
al cirujano verla su cirujano abrirá la
aorta para exponer la válvula aórtica
hará una incisión alrededor del borde de
la válvula dañada y la extraerá luego su
cirujano suturará con cuidado la válvula
de reemplazo en su lugar y cerrará la
aorta con puntos
en este momento se volverá a permitir
que la sangre fluya hacia su corazón
para revisar la función de la válvula
nueva de ser necesario se administrará
una descarga eléctrica para reanimar al
corazón una vez que su corazón lata por
sí mismo se le desconectará de la
máquina de circulación extracorpórea
generalmente se colocarán cables de
marcapasos temporales en la superficie
del corazón para asegurar que éste
mantenga un ritmo normal durante la
recuperación
después de la cirugía se le llevará a la
unidad de cuidados intensivos en donde
se le controlarán sus funciones vitales
seguirá teniendo un tubo respiratorio en
su garganta lo que evitará que hable se
le colocarán varios tubos para drenar la
sangre y los fluidos de su incisión y el
catéter de su vejiga seguirá drenando su
orina